reading writing and activism our
collegiate indoctrination factories
that's the focus of tonight's angle
watching how things have played out
during the first 13 months of the Trump
era I've come to the conclusion that
liberals just aren't that interested in
advocating policies that improve the
lives of Americans but what they do want
and it's part of the Obama legacy is a
constant state of protest and agitation
a resistance force fed to them in their
high school and college years and now
professors themselves are nurturing the
next generation of revolutionaries at
many colleges students are now expected
to skip class to attend social justice
rallies
case in point on Yale's admissions blog
under the title in support of student
protests the assistant director of
admissions writes for those students who
come to Yale we expect them to be versed
in jett issues of social justice
according to Walter Olsen on your Wall
Street Journal Yale does not count
skipping classes for protests like you
know like we've seen lately against
applicants no problem whatsoever now
check this out the Dean of Admissions at
Tufts University her name is Karen
Richardson after the Parkland shooting
issued this statement to applicants she
said I want to assure you that Tufts is
a place where civic engagement is not
only tolerated it's encouraged strongly
so when you act on your values in a
principled way on issues about which you
feel passionately it will not be held
against you in the application process
in fact we may even take notice
so forget volunteering with the elderly
are helping special needs children and
put that on your college application if
you really want to get into that College
of your choice go yell at a conservative
senator and then post it on YouTube
there are other universities also
stoking activism out there at Valdosta
State in Georgia the Women's and Gender
Studies department encourages students
in their division to organize an
implement annual social justice events
such as the intimate partner violence
awareness month and you get productions
of the Vagina Monologues
and National Coming Out Day but
politically perhaps I have to think
about this no one did more to encourage
student organizing like Barack Obama
last year he talked about training the
next generation of community organizers
Mateo and I and others have been talking
about how we can create an effective
network of global activists some who are
in politics some who are in business
some who are in journalism or working
for NGOs and provide them the tools the
training the network's the relationships
the funding so that they can be even
more effective I thought we were
supposed to be training like code
writers to work in the 21st century
economy but we're training the activists
I would say about what the president
said there
they've already been pretty effective
right policing speech codes on college
campuses ejecting administrators who
don't toe their political line and now
pushing for daca and gun control laws
but there's something insidious afoot
here a few years ago Nicholas Christakis
who's the head of a Yale College was
forced to resign after his wife also a
professor dared to send out a mass email
objecting to Yale's Halloween costume
rules she suggested merely that Yale
students be allowed to wear whatever
they want as a costumes kind of
pro-choice even obnoxious or offensive
costumes
well the protest crowd corner Christakis
on the quad he tried to have an actual
discussion with them so we're sitting
here telling you that you are being
racist it shouldn't be a question as to
whether you almost an apology and
empathy bus' is not necessary for you to
understand that you're wrong
first of all this is not a debate did
you hear that well we say admit it now
they're not interested in debate they
would rather grandstand and bully and
hurl insults than actually make a cogent
argument now isn't any wonder why a
knight Foundation survey found that 54%
of college students say the climate on
campuses stifles their expression for
fear of offending others the
indoctrination of these students begins
earlier and earlier I'm talking grammar
and middle school and once reprogrammed
liberal adults deploy these student BOTS
to do their own political bidding just
look at the way they've used the high
school students in parkland certain
Stoneman Douglas students successfully
did use their social media platforms to
spread their anti-gun demands no doubt
about it but let's pull back the curtain
here groups like every town for gun
safety founded by billionaire Michael
Bloomberg gave 2.5 million dollars to
support hundreds of marches for gun
control including the big one later this
month The Washington Post is telling us
that high school students in the st.
Louis area are not only planning a
walkout on April 20th but they're
planning a protest at the office of
Republican Missouri Attorney General
Josh Hawley who wants to unseat Democrat
Senator Claire McCaskill again the goal
here is political power the idea that
this is like merely a student-led
totally organic altruistic crusade to
end gun violence it's deceiving it's not
lead up looking at it carefully enough
the focus here really is power and it's
partisan march on the nearest
conservative
take down one of the biggest advocacy
groups like the NRA you bet
don't fall for all the fresh young faces
you see reciting the liberal tropes
these student protesters are amplified
supported and funded by old guard
liberals Hollywood elites like George
Clooney and Oprah business elites like
Michael Bloomberg and the media Vanguard
at places like NBC and of course CNN so
without all of that support of course
they wouldn't be receiving this
attention and then maybe they'd even be
back at school learning something but
when you can get college credit or maybe
even a fast pass to the Ivy League's by
protesting why study you know hang it
out with Bill Maher and Alan is like
helping me find my voice my truth my
social justice mission totally and
that's the angle